the One Piece manga just set up the
biggest challenge for Luffy and Co in
the story so far as the crew is getting
ready to leave the laboratory on Egghead
Island together with their newest crew
member Dr vegapunk Admiral kizeru is
about to arrive at the island with a
massive Fleet of marine warships and the
narrator says at the end of the chapter
which literally means the Marine
headquarters ultimate military power is
approaching and so this could mean that
we finally get to see an admiral go all
out for the very first time in the story
that would mean that we finally also see
how strong the Admirals truly are and if
the straw hats are actually powerful
enough to take on the strongest people
in Marines but wait a second you might
be wondering how did kizeru get here so
fast well as soon as kizero heard about
the straw hats being on the island he
immediately put one and one together and
figured out that the straw hats would
try and rescue vegapung from the special
agent sent by the government to
assassinate him and you know I think
it's very easy to underestimate kizuru I
mean he always looks like he's the least
motivated out of all the Admirals who
doesn't take anything seriously however
as we know this couldn't be further from
the truth we've seen it many many times
now that kizaru is actually the most
active out of all the Marine Admirals
that we've seen so far I mean let's look
at it green Bowl seems to enjoy lying
around and immediately retreated from
wano once he couldn't easily dominate
his opponents anymore both aokiji and
fujitora are always extremely careful in
their actions taking circumstances and
the people around them into
consideration and even a kainu is
surprisingly passive in his leadership
for instance he refused refuses to
attack wano carefully considering the
Marine's power and what a battle would
mean for his forces so kizuru is really
the only Admiral who is always eager to
jump right into action and so we've seen
a kainu trying to hold him back a number
of times now remember kizaru was willing
to go tuano on his own and face three
yongo at once that takes some serious
balls and I do actually want to explain
all the Marine Admirals in detail so I
will make a dedicated video about that
if at least 1 000 people subscribe until
tomorrow but going back to kizaru did
you also notice that he is clearly not
really eager to take orders from a kainu
because while Akino is getting briefed
on the situation with Luffy and Luchi he
only then realizes that vegapunk
probably knew about the world
government's plan to kill him all along
in the meantime kizaru had not only
gotten that information before the fleet
Admiral but also had already left with
an entire Army without waiting for
permission and as I said the manga
literally says in Japanese the Marine
headquarters ultimate military power is
approaching does that mean an admiral or
does the narrator mean kizeru
specifically because it would be truly a
bombshell if the strongest Marine
fighter would turn out to be neither a
kainu nor aokiji who both fought for the
position of Fleet Admiral but actually
kizaru all along and I mean Kizer
himself at least seems to be quite
confident that he can stop the straw
hats by himself either with sheer
strength or he has something up his
sleeve that he's bringing along with him
so will Luffy actually fight against
kizaru will we finally find out how
strong an admiral is at full strength I
mean it's possible and I think there are
three ways that this could actually go
option one kizaru is about to attack the
straw hats and vegapunk but someone
comes in and rescues the straw hat and
allows them to get away and I do think
this scenario is actually pretty likely
I mean we've seen it happen before for
one we do know know that we have
vegapunk with the crew now and it would
be really surprising if he didn't have a
bunch of tricks up his sleeve in his own
laboratory that would then allow the
crew to escape the incoming Fleet of
Warships on top of that you might also
remember that Kuma has started running
away from the revolutionaries and has
most likely teleported himself towards
where Luffy and his daughter Bonnie are
because that happened exactly the moment
when vegapunk realized that the Agents
of cp0 had infiltrated the islands so
Kuma could be the one to save the crew
once again from kizeru just like he did
on sabaori archipelago and speaking of
that by the way there are a lot of
parallels with Saba ODI and enoslavi
during this Arc like cyborg Frankie vs
cyborg vegapunk the Ohara flashback
during and aslobby and the Ohara
flashback here Luchi vs Luffy version 2
centomaru kizeru and Kuma versus the
straw hats and this time it's sent omaro
Kuma and the straw hats against kizeru
and also there is a real chance that the
Revolutionary Army might show up here as
well again after all Dragon was chasing
after Kuma and trying to stop him from
leaving again and so in the end the
strawheads might just be able to escape
another time and we'll have to wait for
the battle against the Admirals for just
a little bit longer unless we have
option 2 here that is a little bit less
likely but my personal favorites since
the crew is about to set sail and kizaru
is coming with a fleet of ships there is
a chance that we might get to see the
first sea Battle in the history of one
piece I mean I know it sounds crazy but
even though one piece is a story about
Pirates and Marines sailing the giant
oceans of the world we haven't had a
single real sea Battle in the entire
story the closest we've gotten so far
was the crew being chased around like on
whole kick Island for instance so it
would be truly refreshing to see some
actual ship versus ship battle for a
change which would also give Frankie a
real chance to show off his technology
to vegapunk and this would of course
also be a great opportunity for the
straw hat Grand and flee to arrive I
mean imagine the Thousand Sunny all
alone facing a whole Armada of Warships
and then suddenly ships appearing behind
them at the Horizon Not only would that
make for a super epic scene but it would
also be a great chance to bring hirogen
and his giant crew into the story again
to then guide the straw hats to albafv
which let's be honest is most likely the
next destination after this now I do not
know how the grand Fleet would possibly
know about the straw hats being in
danger but it would be truly awesome to
see nonetheless but option number three
would be even better maybe and that's
that the straw hats actually have an
all-out battle with kizaru and the other
Marines now it's really hard to say how
powerful kizaru really is and if Luffy
would be able to defeat him is kizeru
stronger than kaido I mean it seems
unlikely but then again he was more than
eager to go to wano and fight kaido
Luffy and big mom together so who knows
but even if we say that he is a bit
weakert and kaido Luffy has just used
his gear 5 form in his fight with Luchi
and yes he has successfully beaten Luchi
a second time and even oluchi clearly
has become very powerful himself he
couldn't even touch Luffy but
interestingly enough we also see that
Luffy has once again turned into that
old man for him after using his
Awakening so clearly gear 5 is draining
Luffy of his energy and I'm not sure
that he would be able to Simply
reactivate it again if kizuru just
popped up now on the other hand all the
other straw heads are kind of well
rested Zoro and Sanji definitely could
at least put up a decent fight this time
and on top of that we also have seen a
pair of gloves in vegapung's lab that
make it possible to touch light plus an
actual lightsaber that Bonnie picked up
as well so in a way it does seem like
Oda has at least set up a fight with
Admiral kizeru for somebody but on top
of all this epic setup for kizaru and
his Grand Armada we have also had some
other major stuff happening in this
chapter too Luffy's battle with Lucci
was absolutely epic and really fun to
read really we got a bunch of new gear 5
attacks and a ton of references to their
original fight during Anna's Lobby I
mean some of the panels were designed in
the exact same way like this one from
last chapter and this time Luchi also
thinks to himself that his Consciousness
is fading which is the exact same line
that he had on Anna's Lobby I really
think the fight was more something to
just enjoy not really to discuss or
theorize about in depth here I really
like that Lucci was super strong and
didn't go down easily right away but
still couldn't lay a finger on Luffy who
now finally gets the respect that a
yonko really deserves the biggest
takeaway of the entire fight is to me
that the three setup him who were in the
lab have now all gone over to the
government side though it was really
nice seeing them fight as an ally here
for a second and I also really like that
the ceter theme can actually talk and
seem to have real personality as well
because this not only makes them
terrifying weapons but actual character
that can be talked to and interacted
with so it might well be that Luffy will
free them from the government control
too at some point or maybe vegapunk has
secretly inserted dragon as their
Supreme Commander on top of the gorosei
and then we also had even more lore drop
on Vega Punk's artificial devil fruit
because he confirms to us that different
categories of devil fruits are
differently easy or hard to copy Zone
fruits as we already guessed are the
easiest because they are literally based
on animals paramecia fruits on the other
hand require DNA from the user which is
known as the lineage factor in one piece
and logia fruit users are basically
impossible to copy they just really like
being the most unique category of fruits
huh well this of course also explains
why the jinbei seraphim has the swim
swim fruit after doflamingo and his crew
were captured by the Marines and I would
say it is very likely that there is a
Dopey set of him as well with his string
fruit Powers too also this might explain
why Shanks insisted on taking Aces and
whitebeard's body away from a rainforge
to keep the government from stealing his
earthquake Powers as well because let's
be real if anyone knows about this going
on then it's Shanks after all and
speaking of the lineage factor and devil
fruit experiments we also have to talk
about the cover of this chapter as well
where we see younger versions of Dr
vegapunk a slim Queen an emo Caesar and
a really quirky looking judge Vin smoke
I mean look at these designs but it
stood out to me that the judge doesn't
actually have sanji's spiral eyebrows
nor does his mother so I think the idea
that Sanji has received some sort of
devil fruit ability from the lineage
Factor experiments on him seems to have
gotten a lot more proof here and in case
you're wondering that's because his
eyebrows have the same spiral shape that
can also be found on devil fruits and
really we've gotten so much knowledge on
devil fruits and they're Awakening these
last few chapters that as promised I
have condensed everything that we know
so far into this video if you'd like to
get a bit of an overview thanks so much
for watching